what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are picking up with Infinity
Ward's prime number one now I thought
about doing countdown to infinity wars
but it's totally unnecessary it's
basically a guardians of the galaxy
story and the Guardians fight the
gardener it's not even that interesting
of the story the big takeaway from that
well they were like two big takeaways
one is that Galactus goes back to being
the devourer of worlds and Silver Surfer
goes back to being his Herald and the
other one is that there is a character
called Requiem which we'll talk about
her here in a minute because I have a
pretty solid theory on who that
character is but unless initially this
picks up with Loki right this is the
actual infinity Wars story itself and
this is basically the whole event of
like a race for the the Infinity stones
and different people are chasing after
the Infinity stones for different
reasons for example gamora's hunting the
soul stone because she learned there was
a fraction of her soul that was so stuck
in it now in reality that's Jerry Dugan
and Marvel kind of hitting back to the
old jim Starlin stories right like you
go read the old jim Starlin comics from
back in the 80s and 90s and gomorrah
alongside pip the troll and Adam warlock
had spent a brunt of their time inside
of soul world the issue with this was
that it was always believed that when
gomorrah came back that it was it was
her whole incomplete self but we ended
up learning is that a part of herself
was still stuck there and it actually
aged which didn't really make any sense
because in the soul stone nobody ever
ages so it's kind of interesting but
there was basically an old version of
herself that was there and it was the
hunt to find that complete part of
herself and to bring it back and so the
result here is that initially we
basically end up joining with Loki now
Loki's an omnipotent city and for those
of you guys who have been following the
Thor comics for a little while
this originally made its debut back in
2013 with Thor god of thunder number
three I'm pretty sure but basically
omnipotent city was this place it was
designed by writer Jason Aaron to
essentially kind of flesh out the Thor
mythos and build on it right there was
essentially like this big parliamentary
location where originally was built by
the Elder Gods before they died off or
you know were you know essentially
removed for the landscape and that
ultimately is it's kind of served as
like a house of sorts what this also
does is this introduces a guy by the
name of flow of which basically he's a
tomb keeper I'm sorry a tome keeper now
the tome keepers are actually kind of a
new concept in in Marvel and the reason
why is because again Jason Aaron was
building on a lot of things so it takes
it makes sense when you're talking about
the Asgardian mythos because it's such a
huge portion of Marvel Comics right now
because you have the war of realms and
there are a lot of changes that were
made he can't really ignore them
especially when you consider the fact
that Jason Aaron's Ron is
it's multi-faceted run icily going on
for quite some time and so a lot of the
things that are going on with Asgard
either tie into the existing Asgardian
mythos or act as a complement to it of
course we had like the Congress of
Worlds for example and you had like the
the you know this sort of multiversal
library of all these old books in
different things like that but the tone
keepers are guys who basically keep all
these different tomes these sort of
history books and different things like
that these books in a wide array of
different things now the idea behind
this was it originally they were all
confined to a singular location but
Freya the wife of Odin had essentially
made the decision to basically go
through and start splitting them off in
two different locations and this
actually served the purpose of being
beneficial when Asgard was essentially
destroyed and so because Asgard is gone
because now all you have is as Gardea
the version of Asgard that Iron Man
built after the events of siege what you
have now is essentially like all these
different locations around in this sort
of Asgardian realm that has all these
different books on history and artifacts
and things like that and what Loki's
been doing is if anything from what I
can tell is actually poring over what
amounts to what if stories basically
stories that take place in alternate
universes and the reason why is he
starts talking about how like all these
stories have Marvel characters in them
but events basically unfold in different
ways so like spider-man never loses the
Venom symbiote Captain America and never
you know he's never frozen and ice and
he basically becomes present United
States different things like that but
loki is essentially poring over all
these books because in none of these
does he ever actually take over and
become ruler of Asgard look he's always
the backup guy he's always kind of the
guy that never really leads into a
singular place and so the question
becomes what's going on with all this
like information in your books are
incomplete or they're incorrect and we
have to go find factual information well
of course at this point though
a--basically says look you have to go to
the god quarry if you want to figure
that out now of course close you guys
who have been reading fan OHS that god
quarry was invented in that line of
comics and it's basically this idea that
there is a place out there on the edge
of the universe on the edge of like the
you know the dimensional space that if
you can go into the god quarry survive
the test of the three witches which is
to basically not give in to the illusion
that you see then you'll emerge with a
whole you know with a heightened level
of power now the idea is that it's an
enhancement of power
what do get seems to be hitting here is
basically saying it's not just power
it's also knowledge and so it's the idea
that Loki can enter into the god quarry
and then in turn start looking at all
this information that's there and get an
actual account of the various universes
that
just out there now again there's
different ways that this can go we know
that infinity wars is basically gonna
come down to the various possessors of
the of the soul stones facing off
against one another and likely it'll it
may or may not turn into kind of like a
reboot of sorts from all it'll likely be
a soft reboot ah but it'll be like it'll
probably be like a reboot of sorts where
they'll use the reality stone to go
through and start fixing things making
small adjustments different things like
that uh how that will impact things we
don't know but it could be that other
characters from different universes get
pulled in because of Loki's knowledge
with the god quarry he goes to those
different universes grabs them and
brings them over one of the cool things
is that there's gonna be the Infinity
warp which is actually based off the
Jaspers warp and is essentially like the
merging of characters there's a lot of
really cool things they're gonna come
out of infinity wars this summer it
seems like it'll be one of the better
events that Marvel's done in the last
really in the last decade which in truth
kind of makes sense with the exception
of Secret Wars secret Empire Hickman's
Avengers and New Avengers taking those
into account there's only you know
they're like the only a handful of
events it have been great everything
else has just kind of been there it's
just stuff that's happened I still say
to the stage secret Empire is one of the
best Captain America stories ever
written I know people get angry at me
for saying that because I don't because
I'm not agreeing with him but still like
I thought it was an amazing story I
thought it was absolutely awesome but of
course this basically leads to to you
know throw up basically grabbing Loki
and the two of them sort of go on a
journey to the god quarry which is kind
of a cool idea but at this point we
switch over to Adam warlock and Doctor
Strange now remember when it comes to
the soulstone in Marvel Comics Adam
warlock is part and parcel to it I mean
it's as much a part of him as like an
arm or a leg or anything like that
because he spent so much time inside of
it and so much time wielding it I mean
again that goes back to the old jim
Starlin stories this idea that Adam
warlock was given the power so I'm sorry
given the soul stone by the High
Evolutionary on and he used his power to
achieve various feats but found out in
the future he would be driven insane by
it which would lead to the formation of
the Magus and while this goes into the
full publication history of Adam and the
various stories and the fence that have
taken place over the years he's really
found himself instead of entering into a
cocoon of sorts to basically regenerate
instead he would go into the soul stone
and that would be a sort of place of
Solace his kind of Zen location more or
less and so because of the fact that
he's so part and parcel to it but he can
sort of enter and leave as he pleases
but the idea is that people are
gathering the soul stones or I'm sorry
gathering the Infinity stones and that's
why everybody's chasing after them now
for Doctor Strange himself the belief of
Adam was that all the soul stones except
for the I'm sorry out all the ye all the
Infinity stones except for the soul
stone had been destroyed
following the collapse of the multiverse
and its rebirth but dr. strange
basically reveals that he has the soul
stone now this comes out of infinity
wars countdown basically it was the
revelation that the scrolls had gotten
their hands on the hot stone during the
events of that whole thing and like
Planet Hulk 2 and so on and so forth but
this basically leads to the idea that
Stephen strange has it in his possession
and doesn't tell anybody about it and in
reality this is Dugan and company kind
of hitting home at like the Illuminati
like Brian Michael Bendis is Illuminati
which is to say this group of people who
took the soul stones under themselves
I'm sorry the Infinity stones Jesus
under themselves and said no one else is
going to be able to use these things
were the only people who are quote
unquote capable of wielding them without
being corrupted by them with this whole
thing in mind what is up happening is
the idea is to go into the soul stone
and to see what effect the soul stones
having basically you don't kind of see
how everything's going down and when
Adam enters it we're not finding the
soul stone is literally being corrupted
Adam warlock powers don't work here and
so this is really kind of dearie at
Jerry Dugan hitting on the idea that
things were unfolding at a pretty rapid
pace there's a lot of ambiguity here
there's a lot of questions that are
being asked and a lot of questions that
will be answered over time and where dr.
strange is on the outside basically has
a tether attached to Adam to pull him
back out in case of an emergency it
doesn't seem to work and so when dr.
strange enters back in he ends up
finding Adam warlock is like totally
impaled and so it's one of those crazy
things because what ends up happening
here is he manipulates the time stone to
basically pull Adam warlock back out at
least to try to save his life and of
course this leads to Adam warlock
basically saying hey look you've had the
time stone the entire time why didn't
you tell me now this is not the first
time Doctor Strange has done this right
like you use the time stone in such a
fashion by and large the the
manipulation of time in Marvel Comics is
something that you don't usually like to
see people or that people would like dr.
strange don't usually like to use and
the reason why goes back for a variety
of reasons I mean one of the more
tangible reasons came out of the events
of age of Ultron right you know when you
had Wolverine who was jumping back and
forth through time it was sort of this
revelation the time itself is a physical
thing that is slightly like a rubber
band if you pull on it and you allow to
contract enough times eventually you'll
basically destroy its elasticity and
it'll snap and that's really what
happened with like age of Ultron you
know basically the time was
quote-unquote
broken but when you look at things like
this the idea of Doctor Strange is to
say the entire multiverse exists as
branched universe theory that if you go
back in time and you change something
you'll create a wholly new different
universe it won't necessarily affect the
current time
but you don't know what kind of universe
you'll create what kind of beans you'll
lead to because of Marvel Comics you're
talking about a wide array of different
characters some of whom are multiversal
and so what you could end up doing here
is inadvertently creating a universe
we're like Jean Grey never loses the
Phoenix force goes insane by its power
and decides to wipe out the entire
multiverse in the process you could go
through and like inadvertently resurrect
the beyonders and suddenly they're
dealing with time runs out all over
again there's all kinds of different
things that could come with the
manipulation of time and so Doctor
Strange sort of keeping it under wraps
saying look no one's supposed to know
about this is a pretty big deal the
other half of this is that Adam warlock
says look you can keep the time stone in
your possession just know that there are
people out there who were looking for it
and you know that one individual in
particular will come searching for the
Infinity stones it's the nature of who
he is as soon as the multiverse is
recreated as soon as this universe was
restored by Reed Richards in the
Fantastic fork that with the restoration
of the Infinity stones he would come
looking for them this person of course
being Thanos and so it's kind of a cool
thing because what this does is seem to
play on the idea that Thanos is going to
basically try to start capturing the
Infinity stones again and at the outset
it's a little bit like really like
Thanos with the Infinity stones again
it's happened a million times and that's
the the perception that's put off here
because it's like this grandiose speech
you know I leave the army of the
Chitauri the universe is full of
weaklings
you know I will seize the Infinity
stones just like I always do and I will
take absolute power once again the
problem is that while he's making this
speech he's completely impaled by
somebody with a sword and this is when
we get our full-on view of Requiem and
it's cool like Requiem looks pretty
awesome now one of the small things that
have been happening here as part of
infinity wars countdown and they were
like one page things at the beginning of
every story is that this character
Requiem had basically gone to a dwarf
and said fashioned me this particular
type of sword and donned me this type of
armor and if you don't I'll kill you and
that was basically it and that's what
led to Requiem appearing the way it is
the Requiem goes through and literally
just like annihilates Thanos now the
funny thing and here's an important
thing to bear in mind
danos recognizes Requiem is this kind of
like okay I was wondering how long it'll
be before you got here now this has led
into a litany of theories some people
have said that Requiem is like Gomorrah
other people speculate direct liam is
nebula that is basically like a repeat
of Infinity Gauntlet a lot of people are
speculating all these different things
if I were a betting man I bet all the
money in my pockets to all the money
your pockets that Requiem is actually
file Avella and the reason why I say
this is because for those you guys who
don't know and I imagine there's a lot
of people who don't know file of val is
the biological daughter of the original
Captain Marvel who of course was one of
the members of the Creek now of course
the original Captain Marvel died in 1984
but while while different characters
went on to take over the mantle final
val is one of the most notable versions
she eventually went on to become become
the newest version of quasar but when it
comes to file of Ella's character she
was awesome I mean she would do she was
badass there was a point where she
became a bit of a villain but the whole
reason why I say I think it's her is
because one Thanos recognizes her - she
kills Thanos now this is kind of a
mirror reflection of what we saw in
realm of Kings when Thanos emerges from
a cocoon having been resurrected and
immediately kills file avail so like I
would say that's probably her but still
following this like it's basically a
crusade to take out Thanos and
everything Dano stands for because we're
the laws of combat in the Chitauri
society basically say you keep what you
kill something is something that can
select the Chronicles of Riddick what
this means is that she's now the leader
of the Chitauri army and in response she
kills them all but she uh nya lates them
all in their entirety and she basically
says this is it this is what's going to
happen here you know I'm essentially
taking over the entirety of this whole
thing I've wiped out Thanos Thanos is
gone and we have no real idea what her
motivations are but again I think the
idea of it being file eval is awesome
because if she's the daughter of the
original Captain Marvel then what
that'll do is it'll bring her in Carol
Danvers into direct conflict and
basically she could show up and say you
don't need to be here and I think it
would lead to an awesome fight between
the two and so it's just kind of like
like man like this is an awesome concept
you could do so many cool things out of
this it could very well just turn out
this nebula and that's it but I think
it'd be a little disappointing if it
turned out to be nebula because it's too
predictable of an idea ultimately the
story's supposed to end in October and
so in reality you'll find out who it is
if it if it is nebula you'll find that
out depending on what happens in like
Avengers 4 like how the trailer unfolds
with Avengers 4 it because that you guys
Marvel Comics is kind of copying the
Marvel Cinematic Universe and so like
that'll you basically give away the
ending how this whole thing ends with
regards to like Avengers 4 you know
that'll really kind of kind of seal the
deal here but it's a cool concept and
it's a cool idea um I'm really hoping
that it's not a brand new character
because what Marvel has a tendency to do
is to create a brand new character and a
writer does something awesome with them
you know like
and bye-bye Kevin groove oh and then
like it's this amazing introductory
story and then no one ever knows what to
do with him so they basically just get
shuffled off to the cornfields and you
never really hear from them again
whereas if this is a care for this long
since lost then you can basically throw
them back into the shuffle in the same
while they've always been in or create a
new one for them and then like
everything becomes awesome after that so
I'm pretty excited like I'm free height
to see how all this is gonna unfold okay
so um my girlfriend says I open always
hope my videos that way and I never
really noticed it before but apparently
I do now that I think about it it's like
learning about my speech cadence that
like apparently I talk a certain way
they like it like my voice goes up and
then it goes down and I never noticed
that before
apparently that pattern is what makes my
voice ooh think I have no idea we are
covering infinity wars
alright so infinity wars basically deals
with this kind of mad dash for like the
Infinity stones right and at the outset
and we saw this in infinity Wars Prime
at the outset it was like okay Thanos is
hunting the Infinity stones again which
is kind of par for the course like the
Viet the Infinity stones are almost part
and parcel to Thanos his character but
in that story at the end someone named
Requiem killed Thanos and then it was
kind of like okay that's insane and so
right now what we were what we're doing
is we're kind of picking up in the
aftermath of that and really the the the
recognition from the various superheroes
on earth that someone's hunting the
Infinity stones now what we do here is
we pick up initially with Gamora no
gamora's meeting with Peter quill and
it's kind of a cool moment because what
she says is that a piece of her is
missing and to talk about this for a
second I want to discuss the concept of
soul world inside the soul stone so when
it comes to Marvel Comics back when
you're really uh
jim Starlin was writing the old adam
warlock and the old Danno stories and so
on and so forth
soul world was introduced in such a way
to where it was a universal world across
the board which is to say it's a world
inside the soul stone and it looks the
same to everybody in it there is no
differentiation there what Marvel's done
recently is they basically take in the
marvel cinematic universe version of
soul world and they've thrown it into
the comics which seems to indicate the
idea that the structure and the form of
soil world is relative to each
individual soul that's in it right it's
like it's like the afterlife essentially
from like the old x-men comics from
Chris Claremont when Jean Grey as the
white Phoenix meets with death and death
basically says we have all these pillars
here and each one of these pillars is
the afterlife for each individual person
changing it now Gamora we
that part of her is still stuck in there
now the the indication here is that
she's always been there that where she
and an Adam warlock and pip Patrol had
basically sacrificed their lives back in
the the later days of the Thanos war
back when Jim Stalin was writing it
that's where Adam warlock had left
completely and so did pip the troll a
portion of Gomorrah stayed behind now
again as we know that's Marvel's way of
kind of working in the end of infinity
war into the comic book landscape and
then telling a story based off of that
but the fact remains here Becca Moore is
trying to find a way to basically get
that piece of her soul back that's
really what all this has been and so
she's essentially the first of many
people who seem to be going after the
Infinity stones for their own individual
reasons and what she ends up doing is
actually you know taking the taking the
power stone along with her now one of
the other things to bear in mind here is
that of course Peter quill has a power
stone as the aftermath to essentially
the entire lead-up countdown to infinity
wars and so if you want to check that
out you can check out countdown but all
countdown is is really just a series of
guardians of the galaxy stories and
they're not super important I mean
they're cool but they're by no means
required reading but suffice it to say
the guardians of the galaxy are
basically disbanded this at this point
the team doesn't really exist anymore
and so with Gamora leaving what we end
up doing is picking up with group now
for those who guys who are not current
the fact that Groot is speaking full
sentences will strike you as weird like
he'll just kind of be like what you know
group can now speak yes that was part of
the countdown to infinity wars but it
was a battle with the gardener and
essentially the gardener was of course
one of the elders of the universe and
what ended up happening is that where
the floor colossi were basically
defeated and so on that Groot was
adjusted so that he was no longer
relegated to saying his own name that he
can now he could basically speak full
sentences but he's required to say it in
the third person which is why he'll say
Groot told you Gamora would not join us
you know and so what we do from here is
we pick up with the actual superheroes
of earth proper which is to say Adam
warlock and and Raksha destroyer and so
on and they're basically meeting up with
like all these villains which is kind of
a weird scenario it's not something you
normally seek but these are not these
are by no means like high-profile
villains right like you've got Turk
you've got bullseye you've got Sandman
where you've got what basically are our
street-level villains and it's kind of a
smart move and the reason for this is
because what Doctor Strange is doing is
he's calling together the second
iteration of the Infinity watch which is
what Tsar Lord what Peter quill is
essentially showing up to join now for
those of you guys who are new to Marvel
Comics the Infinity watch is most likely
like it'll be the litmus test for the
Marvel Cinematic Universe
most likely I would wager that those
individuals who decide whose contracts
are up and who don't want to come back
or who want to take a break they'll
become part of the infinity watch and
they'll be shuffled off into the
universe somewhere and you'll probably
never see them except for like one or
two times but the Infinity watch was a
team that was created by jim Starlin in
the aftermath of Infinity Gauntlet and
then in turn became like actually pretty
long-running team for a while you had
like moon dragon you had pip the troll
you had Drax a destroyer you had Thanos
who had Adam warlock and I want to say
you had Gamora but basically what had
happened here was at the end of Infinity
Gauntlet because spanos had gone crazy
because Adam warlock was deemed not
worthy of wielding the Infinity Gauntlet
proper ah in turn the lovely tribunal
decreed that the gems would never work
in unison again and that Adam warlock
had to disperse them so that the gems
could still be used where they couldn't
form the gauntlets so the mine stone
still worked the time stone space stone
reality stone so on so forth they all
still work independently
but in order to make sure that no one
would try to you know gather them
together again or to make sure that
nobody would ever you know get each
individual stone use it for their own
ends Adam warlock form the Infinity
watch and they were designed for the
purpose of just safeguarding the
Infinity stones that's all they really
did Doctor Strange calling this together
is done for the purpose of finding a way
to secure the stones and his idea here
is that the stones have to be removed
from the face of the earth they have to
be taken away here because if they
remain here they're in a centralized
location and they're easy to access
now Doctor Strange adopting this idea
actually comes out of his experience
with the Illuminati that was the problem
when all these guys came together in
form the Illuminati they do one of the
first things they did was sit you know
seek out the Infinity stones and then
keep them in unison keep them together
and then in turn disperse each of them
to a member of the Illuminati for
safekeeping but they were all held on
earth and so if anybody decided to show
up on earth and then take the stones it
would be much much easier as opposed to
if they were scattered all across the
universe and so that's the response of
Doctor Strange here we have to find a
way to one keep these things safe and
move them all over the place - basically
scatter them all across the cosmos so
they won't be easily accessible now of
course for some of the guys who are here
the kind of question is what even is all
this because remember for a lot of
street-level characters they don't
really know what Infinity stones are but
then you have someone like Turk Barrett
who basically uses the limestone he's
kind of a street-level guy he was
originally a henchman for for kingpin
and then he in turn got a hold of the
mine stone and then started listening to
the mines of like stockbrokers in people
like that and basically started jumping
into insider trading
and so by listening to you know using
the mind stone to realize what was going
on behind the scenes what people were
thinking about various stocks and so on
he would shift his investments
accordingly and they made himself super
rich was actually a pretty smart way
because how else are they gonna trace it
to insider trading I mean there's no
conceivable way to and so from there
like it's people just kind of asking
questions now the other part of this is
that Adam warlock even chimes in and
says there's something going on with the
soul stone it's corrupted in some way
now for people who've been reading
Marvel Comics for a long time the fact
that Adam warlock is not the one leading
leading the charge is a very big deal
and again this is just reminiscent of
the Marvel Cinematic Universe is one of
those things where Marvel is bringing
the college closer in line with the
movies because if this is if the Marvel
Cinematic Universe didn't exist and this
story was published Adam warlock o Butte
was most likely be the one assembling
the infinity watch but the entire
success or failure of the defeat of
Thanos and infinity war in Avengers 4
rests on the shoulders of the plan of
Doctor Strange and so it makes sense a
Doctor Strange in the comics would be
the one running the show because
Marvel's trying to make sure they're
kind of caught in there they're kind of
brought closer in line here now it's
kind of crazy because remember when it
comes to the Infinity stones you don't
have to use them all in unison you can
use a couple of them together and that's
what Doctor Strange does Doctor Strange
actually uses the time stone alongside
the reality stone and piers and
essentially grants himself cosmic
awareness momentarily only to discover
that Thanos has been killed and that's
what that's that's the whole basis
behind this because if Thanos is hunting
for the Infinity stones which is what
all the rumors had been indicating that
it made sense to form the Infinity watch
but if Thanos has been killed then the
question becomes who in the hell killed
him and so from there what we end up
doing is picking up with Loki what Loki
is doing here is traveling to the god
quarry and the reason why is because
even Loki himself has questions about
what's going on with the bigger picture
and different things like that and it's
gonna be kind of interesting here
because what Jerry Duggan's gonna do is
he's gonna tease something pretty
important what ends up happening is when
Loki gets to the god quarry he ends up
running into the coven the three witches
now for those who guys who don't know
the the inclusion of the god quarry here
is a little intriguing because when Jeff
Lemire introduced the god quarry in the
Thanos line of stories the concept
seemed to be that those who enter the
god corium it's kind of a place where
old gods go to die so kind of like it's
kinda like the bar of the fulcrum for
the Celestials was like where they go to
die and then pass on to whoever
Celestials go in they die but for this
it's basically various gods but a person
can go to the god quarry and they can
submit themselves to the test of the
quarry and what it'll do is it'll
basically put them through a
psychological and physical test kind of
you know bending reality and giving them
like the one universe they always wanted
to exist and if they pass the test then
they're given the power of the God Cory
if they fail they're locked there
forever but the fact remains that when
Loki gets here and he starts talking to
the coven the coven's initial response
is like everything is at an end like
eternity is ending and then in response
the god Cory seems to be destroyed and
the coven is basically gone that seems
to be what's going on there because what
ends up happening is you end up having
this version of Loki who crashed lands
into the main Marvel Universe he's got a
hammer he's got Thor's hammer and he has
the Infinity stones which is kind of
crazy here but this is an alternate
reality version of himself but this is
exceedingly important this is probably
one of the most important things we're
gonna have here because what happens is
when the main Marvel Universe Loki
starts talking to this you know uber
version of himself god Loki or whatever
you want to call them infinity Loki I
think it's kind of infinity Loki I think
is a cool name what you have is the
infinity Loki refer to something called
the original universe and this is kind
of crazy here because Marvel hasn't done
this yet now this is kind of a cool
moment because what this seems to
indicate is maybe the role the Infinity
stones has shifted and what I mean by
that is in Marvel Comics the Infinity
stones are only relative to the universe
they're in right like you can't take the
Infinity stones from you know the main
model universe and then show up in the
real world and use them or like show up
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe and use
that right it doesn't work that way
Thanos can't leave the Marvel Cinematic
Universe with the Infinity stones take
them to the main Marvel Universe and
wreak havoc right the the power of the
Infinity stones can only be used in that
particular universe and we know that
from a variety of different stories and
so what goes on here as it seems like
the Infinity stones are almost like
inability to gain passage from one
universe to the next that khana seems to
be the case and that would make sense
because if what this guy's saying is
true it if what Jerry Dugan is hitting
on is true then it would seem like all
existing Infinity stones all across the
cosmos all originated with the original
universe and if that's true it would
almost be like creating a bridge to
access that original universe because
notice the way the jury didn't write
says this version of Loki doesn't say
you can't access all the other universes
without urines Finity stones assembly
the statement you can't access the
original universe so it makes sense and
so what ends up happening is is this
version of Loki goes back to his own
universe you know kind of teleports back
to the battle that he's fighting at
which involves like all these
superheroes right like the Avengers and
and like the Asgardians and so on and so
forth and why
there they're all killed by a Soul Eater
like they're all basically wiped out
completely it's kind of crazy because
switching back to dr. strange and
switching back to the the various
members of the of the infinity watch as
they're formed what we end up doing is
is the whole group is met by the arrival
of like Thor and Iron Man and it's kind
of the question of what in the hell is
going on here right now like what is
this and so where you have like the
villains who kind of break into a fight
against the heroes and nobody really
trusts anybody and so on and so forth
then they're met with the arrival of
Requiem the person that killed fan OHS
and all eyes turn to whoever in the heck
this character is and it's kind of nuts
because from here like like Requiem
basically has the power stone in their
sword and so that's what the question
kind of has to be asked if Gomorrah took
the power stone then did Requiem kill
Gomorrah and take it and it's kind of
cool because if that's the case then
recrea is insanely dangerous because
Gomorrah was one of the most powerful
fighters in in though in the Marvel
Universe and so people begin asking the
question who in the heck are you and of
course Brooklyn responds by saying
tano's referred to me as his Requiem and
so that's what I am like I am I am
Requiem and the various characters start
to go on the offensive right like roots
the first one to attack roots the first
one taken down Peter quill uses his
freeze gun like all these people start
firing on Requiem then rocket racoon
comes out of nowhere and blows requiems
helmet off only for us to find out that
is been Gamora the whole time and it's
just kind of like damn because like
Gamora killed Thanos and it makes sense
right like it makes perfect sense victim
more would be the one to do I mean again
Marvel's Rowling the Marvel Cinematic
Universe over into the comics slowly and
slowly you know a bit by bit and so of
course given what's happened in the MCU
it makes sense that Gamora would be
intertwined and she'd be the one to take
down Thanos which I don't know if that
will happen in Avengers 4 but if I were
a betting man I'd say Gamora will be the
one to kill thanos but even then as long
as a history as she's had in Marvel
Comics and as long as she's been an
enemy of Thanos in Marvel Comics it
makes sense that she would be the one to
kill him or her or nebula like Neverland
might be the one to take Fanus down but
at the end of the day it ends up being
like a Maura who is the one who kills
him and what she ends up saying is like
I did this because I'm on a quest for
the soul stone like I'm on a quest for
the Infinity stones and the soul stones
himself and so if you can't do this to
me if you can't help me out if you're
gonna get in my way then I'll take all
of you out like that's just the way it
is like I will take out every single one
of you like I'll destroy you all and
Gamora will Peter quill goes to collar
bluff right lay-oh Peter Quill's like
well no you're not like I've I fought
with you forever like I fought with you
for a long time we even got into the
galaxy we've been lovers together like I
know
not gonna kill me and her response is
yes I will Peter and she plunges her
sword right through his chest and
impales him and it's just like wow
Gamora just killed star-lord it's pretty
crazy
okay so we're getting into infinity wars
oh really infinity Wars part two this is
basically coming off the heels of like
Gamora capturing the Infinity stones
which is kind of weird the idea that
Gamora was basically a character called
Requiem who killed Thanos honestly I
felt like it was way too early for a
reveal I'm not really sure why Geri
Dugan decided to drop the reveal so fast
but maybe there's other crazy stuff in
store the only thing I can surmise here
is that Avengers 4 is gonna end with
Gamora taking out Thanos and so it was
more like an editorial mandate because
we know like like Marvel is kind of
adjusting the comics to copy the the
Marvel Cinematic Universe and so it's
kind of interesting but the fact remains
here that what this does is kind of pick
up with the past a little bit and it
really kind of gives us like this
continual journey with regards to Gamora
scare to remember she's part of a race
called the Zen wall beerus and her
people were wiped out by another group I
think it was the oh god what was it it
starts with a be the badoon I gave a
rough top my head anyway it's when she
was an adult she went back and wiped out
the people who wiped out her people so
when she was younger of course Thanos
taking her under his wing really taught
her to be pretty hardcore I mean
basically turning you know helped to
turn her into like one of the world and
one of the universe's most you know
four-digit assassins really the most
dangerous woman in the universe but one
of the things that Thanos talks about
here and this is kind of interesting
one of the things he talks about here is
the idea that basically everything ends
you know that everything will die at
some point or another and he really
follows this ideology that like only the
strongest life you know only the
strongest live survive know this is kind
of uncharacteristic of Thanos as
character and the reason why I say that
is right now in Marvel Comics in the
present day Thanos is kind of abandoned
the idea of mistress death right he
walked away from that and said she's
basically a lost cause and say didn't
want to have anything to do with it but
then like when you go back and you look
at that hose in the past he was very
much enamored with mistress death and so
it wouldn't really make a whole lot of
sense for him to adopt this mentality
that like only the strong deserve to
survive because the governing factor of
Thanos and everything he did was
attaining the affections of mistress
death and so it would make more sense
here if he said well I I killed him to
please mistress death you know because
death wants death like you know the the
sacrifice of life or life is meaningless
because of course he's a nihilist or
something along those lines he doesn't
really say that he's kind of hints to
like kind of an extreme social darwin
it's perspective that only the strong
deserve to survive and it's kind of a
funny thing because Gamora
by saying well I mean if that's true
then the time will come when you will
die I mean you told me as much but like
somebody will kill you and Thanos
recognizes it and says yes that's the
nature of things the universe is
grooming someone to take me out so again
it's not really characteristic of Thanos
for us to hear him talk that way and
that's why it's so treated so intriguing
because there's obviously a lot of
influence here coming from the Marvel
Cinematic Universe is being copied over
into the comics or I guess the comics
copying over into the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and so again you know picking
up with Gamora killing Thanos what we
also find out here is it wasn't so
clear-cut you know where she well no pun
intended
but where she she cut off his head that
Thanos actually began speaking to her
telepathically now this is ambiguous
here and we don't really know exactly
how this Falls with Thanos sort of
walking away from mistress death and
really kind of leaving her behind ah
Thanos going his own way Oh what this
basically meant was it seems like Thanos
may have been barred from the realm of
mistress death and if that's true his
Kapoor I guess his essence may continue
to live on but historically speaking in
Marvel Comics when someone like like
take for example Deadpool is barred from
from the realm of the Dead or even when
it comes to comes with a nose himself
who was banned from the realm of
mistress death there's simply just
immortal they just can't die their
spiritual essence doesn't live on their
physical body just can't be destroyed
it's impossible to kill them because
there's nowhere for them to go and so
it's kind of crazy here because of
course you know Gamora responds by
wiping out the rest of the Chitauri army
and that really kind of brings them to a
reason to a close and so it switches
back over to the really with a the last
story left off when Gamora killed
star-lord when she killed Peter quill
now of course if you want to want to
know what's going on there check out the
video down in the description of course
so you know we also have the infinity
war playlist and so on but where she
goes to impale him what we end up having
is Doctor Strange
invoking the time stone and stopping
time now this is kind of an intriguing
move because of course this is obviously
again you know the Marvel Cinematic
Universe being rolled in and Doctor
Strange basically saves Peter quill and
of course he doesn't heal him that
doesn't happen right off the bat I said
he just basically kind of saves him and
then from there you know he actually
goes to the process of healing him you
know as soon as all that's done but it's
intriguing here because not everyone
knows how to react and so what you end
up having Doctor Strange basically doing
is taking like taking Turk Turk Turk
Barrett and then whisking him off to
another to another dimension
now what Doctor Strange is doing here is
basically pitching a kind of a middle
ground and the reason why is remember
Turk got the mind stone and what it
allowed him to do was read the minds of
like stockbrokers and things like that
and start investing his money in a way
that turned him until I get a man who
is worth you know mountains and
mountains of money worth an absolute
fortune and so dr. strange response is
we have to get the Infinity stones off
the planet Earth if we have them all in
a singular location there'll be that
much easier for Gamora to access so we
have to disperse them all across the
cosmos
and turn it into a hunt that would take
her thousands of years to finally figure
out but remember this is one of the
things that that that uh no fury Dugan
seems to forget or if you just do it in
the story and dr. strange forgot but
remember the Infinity stones want to be
brought together we know that from Brian
Michael Bendis is Illuminati run we know
it from Jonathan Hickman's Avengers and
New Avengers run if you have one stone
it'll lead you to all the others because
they want to be reunited remember they
all hail from a singular being this
constantly trying to reform itself and
where we would think that Gomorrah would
still be a neo basically a lost ball in
high weeds trying to track these stones
down remember she has the power stone in
a power stone in her sword so she
already has a kind of homing beacon for
the rest of the Infinity stones wherever
they happen to be the smart is decision
by dr. strange would be to scouted and
scattered them across different
dimensions to take them to like
different dimensions now that may very
well have been the plan and it seems
like the most likely thing at least
given Doctor Strange is power because in
that case the more would never be able
to find them but neither would anybody
else it would literally be everyone
relying on Stephen strange to make the
decision to reform the gems and then
presumably reform the Infinity Gauntlet
if the crisis was bad enough but again
it's it's pretty cool here you know it's
pretty intriguing because in the middle
of this fight that's continually going
on between the guardians of the galaxy
and and you know this sort of hodgepodge
of our superheroes and the various
villains who were there we end up having
like Iron Man who arrives on the scene
now again this is coming down with the
big guns this is when the big guys are
stepping in and saying look this has
gone on long enough we're in this kind
of a situation we've basically been
dealing with like small fries for the
most part I mean you got Doctor Strange
who's not really a small fry but for the
most part it's it's really you know
small fries through everything else and
this of course leads into like we're
showing up to meet with Peter quill to
meet with uh meet with star-lord Carol
Danvers makes her arrival as well this
is kind of a cool thing and I like how
Jerry Dugan does this is he doesn't
really pull any punches with the
character of Gamora and the reason why
is because she's extremely capable I
mean she got super street superhuman
strength speed and durability and all
those different things and while she's
not necessarily a pound for pound match
for Carol Danvers or at least it doesn't
really seem like she would be do be
really kind of like amps her powers up a
little bit and actually says yes she is
now of course this also comes my way of
her wielding the power stone and that
gives her kind of a boost to the energy
that she had before remember the power
stone is basically like
power given form so energy projections
superhuman strength anything that
involves a a power based element it
would allow a person to amplify their
abilities multiple times over whatdo gun
also seems to do is sort of limited
limited in scope because the Infinity
stones are not finite stones the
Infinity stones are literally infinite
and so wielding the power stone gives
you infinite power punching Carol
Danvers knocking her unconscious it
seems pretty straightforward this of
course leads to Thor throwing his hammer
Captain America throwing his shield and
everyone's looking to try to face off
against Gamora and take her out this is
actually a genius moment here it's one
of the one of the one of the coolest
moments of the story and Jerry Dugan
really kind of pulls a rabbit out of his
hat here the way this goes down is you
end up having Carol Danvers grabbing
Gamora and whisking her into space now
Carol Danvers depending on the story
depending on the circumstance she can
tap into her binary powers occasionally
and it'll allow her to like breathe in
space and different things like that
when she flies Gamora up into the air it
resumed ibly knocks her out because the
oxygen is so thin and the result is that
she basically brings her back down but
notice this it's so cool because you end
up having dr. strange who goes to bind
goo goes to bind Gamora and that's
basically the end of that and of course
she's she's basically tied up but then
she starts tapping in Morse code and
Captain America immediately picks up on
this and that's when he realizes that
they've basically switched it's actually
Carol Danvers who's laying on the ground
and it's Gamora who's who's essentially
you know appearing as Carol Danvers and
the reason why is because Gamora has the
reality stone this is one of the coolest
uses of the reality stone in Marvel
Comics history because you never really
see it used on like a small scale you
never really see someone distort reality
in such a way to make them appear to be
someone else and when Gamora realizes
that Captain America you know
understands what's going on she simply
says I really didn't want it to happen
this way all you had to do was play
along not ask any questions from there
Gamora single-handedly dismantled the
entirety of the Avengers team she takes
them apart piece by piece and this is
really kind of like a love letter to the
Gamora fan saying hey look she's just as
dangerous as you think she is even
though she's kind of you know falling
back to the wayside after the events of
like annihilation conquest
even though she hasn't really been
relevant for was essentially like 12
years he's really been more of like a
background character a supporting
character she still is incredibly
dangerous and she still is incredibly
capable in terms of her abilities and
it's cool to see because you end up
having Adam warlock
whose head is cut off because gomorrah
knows he'll just continually fight over
in over and over again black widow who
jumps in you end up having like black
panther who shows up and then she just
freezes time and she stops everything
and it says like everything is done and
then of course you know you end up
having Thanos who appears to her for a
moment and so what she does is she
basically you know once when she gets
the soul stone from Adam warlock she
opens a portal to soul world now again
this is interesting here because this is
this is again Jerry Dugan really hitting
at the idea and creating a story by
simply saying that Gomorrah wasn't
really as free as she thought as we
thought she was
now again he's also shifting up the
nature of the soul stone in the sense
that what he seems to be doing here is
saying that unlike years past where you
had soul world inside the soul stone and
soul world was universal meaning
everybody saw the same thing they could
interact with each other it'd be like
walking around the city of New York
instead the interior of the soul stone
seems to be relative to the person who's
in it and so nobody can interact with
anybody else because they're in their
own their own individual version of soul
world and that's probably what you'll
end up seeing basically with with the
events of infinity war what you're gonna
end up having here is is what amounts to
like marble generations combined with
like the events of soul world and then
like the ribbon or the Nexus or whatever
it was from Star Trek generations that
terrible movie oh you're gonna have this
scenario where like you have all these
everybody who died in infinity war
they're gonna be in their own individual
soul world most likely and they may not
want to leave they may think it's like
you're actually an absolute reality so
again it's it's it's kind of cool and
it's kind of intriguing because it
leaves I'm almost lit on it you know
unlimited possibilities but when
gomorrah goes to merge with herself her
response is now I'm going to use the
Infinity stones I'm going to bring them
together and I'm gonna use them for a
singular purpose at which point Loki
appears and says actually I have a much
much better idea on how these things can
be used effectively okay so picking back
up again with infinity wars the third
installment infinity wars part 3 this
really feels like it kind of spoils the
ending of Avengers 4 although probably
not but a good more again has the
Infinity stones now again this is weird
when it comes to get more scared she's
always been solid like a more has always
been like pretty soft but it seems like
such a sudden shift it's just kind of
weird to see your shift up like this but
the idea is that she's wielding all the
Infinity stones and basically Loki had
tried to find some way to barter with
her now
this is kind of the funny thing is
because gomorrah's been the round she's
been around the block more than a few
times so she's familiar not really super
familiar with Loki but she's familiar
with people like Loki and so we're lucky
pup sup and he's just kind
whispering these honeyed words and so on
and so forth she immediately sees right
through it cuz rumor the goal of loci is
to to figure out what in the world is
going on here in terms of how to
basically stop it all happening because
when he got we received a vision I guess
really when he was met with an alternate
reality version of himself we ended up
finding out this battle is raging this
this exact kind of battle is raging
across the entirety of the multiverse
and in fact the way that this plays out
if Stannis's kind of essence or his
invisible spirit you know it's
consciousness or whatever appears to
Cumorah
assist with the Infinity stones you
would be able to peer into other
universes and see if this is true now
this is new this is not something we'd
ever seen before
the Infinity stones historically never
allowed anybody to do anything that
wouldn't that would any former fashion
impact other universes it doesn't work
that way that was really kind of
solidified during Hickman's Avengers and
New Avengers when Captain America tried
to push another universe away and
destroy the gems in the process so it's
just one of these things where Italy
allows you to manipulate and control the
fundamental forces of a particular
universe so in reality it's really kind
of Jerry Dugan cooking the books a
little bit noir to tell the story but it
works because when they appear into
another universe there is a character
that's known as Requiem but it's not
Gamora it's somebody else entirely now
who that person is has never revealed to
us but Gamora herself really kind of
like disregards this and says I don't
really care like that doesn't have
anything to do with me I'm controlling
this universe right now this universe is
the only one that I'm worried about now
this is kind of cool because under
normal circumstances somebody else may
have gone to investigate like someone
like Thor or somebody like Captain
America or somebody along those lines
even a villain like Ultron may have may
have been like well if I can look into
other universes I can conquer other
universes and just kind of go from there
but for Gamora
she's very on-the-nose very cutthroat
and very straight and narrow and so in
this circumstance
it's basically I'm only worried about
what I can see and what I can do here
I'm not gonna be distracted by anything
else which is kind of cool because
following that she basically releases
everybody from the time stone because
they've basically been frozen in time
this whole time she releases everybody
for the time stone and then says all of
you guys are gonna end up getting in my
way I'm gonna fold space onto itself now
we're not really that's kind of the
crazy thing we're not really given a
motivation for why she's really doing
any of this
she just is and that's why it's kind of
crazy is because her pursuit of of the
Infinity stones really that the soul
stone seemed to be based on the idea
that she was trying to reclaim a portion
of herself that had always been trapped
in there ever since she Adam warlock
and patrol first entered and so that
made sense now she's just doing it for
the sake of doing it and there doesn't
really seem to be a reason why she's
just kind of folding the universe in
half because whatever the story needs to
be told so it's kind of it's kind of
strange that she would be the one to do
all this it's kind of a weird scenario
but nonetheless and going through and
basically saying that you guys have
become more than more or less a hassle
you as superheroes
I'm gonna fold the universe in on itself
and then whatever happens happens what
she doesn't foresee is that they all
begin to kind of merge into each other
this is Jerry Dugan really grabbing a
page out of the old amalgam comics those
guys who don't know what that is back in
the day Marvel and DC had a couple
different crossovers you had Marvel vs.
DC and then you had jla/avengers Justice
League of America and the Avengers the
the model versus DC was actually the
better one jla/avengers was okay but
what you ended up getting out of that
was you basically had amalgam and it was
a universe where the heroes were merged
where you had like dark claw which was
Batman and Wolverine merged into a
single person just different things like
that and it was cool for what it was but
this is kind of a page out of that the
difference here is that it's isolated
strictly to Marvel comics and so where
these characters are really just kind of
relegated and they're sort of confined
the first person we end up picking up
with in this kind of new universe here
is really like Captain America and
Doctor Strange
out really steeped you know private
Steven Rogers who have been merged into
a singular being together and it's kind
of a cool thing because this creates a
whole universe unto itself now this is
very House of M in terms of how all this
goes on the difference here the didn't
between this story in house of him his
House of M was a lot more complex it was
a lot more sprawled out it was a lot
more a lot more in depth and there was a
lot more going on there I mean you mean
you read like the main house of him
stories it's like seven issues long or
six issues long or having many issues is
maybe like 12 I can't we're off top my
head you read all the tie ins you're
starting you're getting into like the
150 issue range and the tie-ins expand
the whole thing they give you like this
whole universe of House of M the whole
reality and how everything had changed
and all that stuff and it was pretty
cool for what it was it was reminiscent
of like Age of Apocalypse or something
like that but for Gamora she didn't
actually expect this to happen she
didn't actually expect that the
characters would merge together and this
is a small but noticeable thing because
what it means is that Gamora
did not consider all ends and that makes
sense because when it comes to someone
like fan O's he's wheeled he's been in
control of absolute power a whole bunch
of times but he's also lived for so long
Thanos is all these thousands of years
old also when you're talking about
someone who is that old if you're
talking about a guy who's been across
the universe who's had a lot of time to
expand his knowledge expand his
experience and who's coming to the table
with more than just I want to have the
Infinity stones and I want to wipe out
half life the universe maybe you have a
guy that has like far more motivation
and it's far more complex and in-depth
than that and so he's able to view
things from perspectives Becca Moore
couldn't consider because she hasn't had
the experience to give her a reason to
consider it and so it's kind of cool
because from there you end up having
Loki who basically says look what you
have there is you have the God for you
know on the far edge of the universe
you've got the God court below that is
the quarry of creation and it's
basically a new concept really kind of
seeming to hit on the idea that all the
universes that exist in our comics all
stem from the quarry of creation now we
don't really know what it is we don't
know how how this whole thing functions
we don't know what process it serves and
and we'll find out you know as the story
goes on but it's kind of cool because
from here haven't got more a peek out of
this universe that she's basically made
and looking at everything that's going
on we have like like Iron Man and Thor
who merge into one you've got black
panther and Ghost Rider who merge Black
Panthers riding like an actual Panther
which looks pretty badass you have what
looks like Scarlet Witch and x-23 homers
it's kind of a cool thing it actually
looks pretty awesome and it sucks it is
so short-lived I mean we do get through
the Infinity warps which give you the
story of all those characters and so on
which we will cover up but still with
Loki trying to more or less swindle his
way in book passage alongside Gamora in
order to access the god quarry and the
quarry of creation ultimately he's
basically set aside by by Gamora her
responses you are not coming here
because you are dubious you are a person
who tricks you're a person that cannot
be believed and ultimately I believe
that your your bases are near or your
entire distance isn't a Farias and so
Loki himself is confined to this new
universe now it's kind of a weird thing
because the way this is done we don't
know exactly how Gamora resides if the
universe has been folded in on itself
that would mean she was folded along
with it but there's no indication she
stands outside of the universe and if
that's true if she does stand outside
the universe then things get a little
hairy because at that point technically
speaking the Infinity stones should shut
off they should just cease to work and
she's just a person kind of floating out
in Oblivion so it's a little strange in
terms of how this happens but again the
other half of this could very well be
the universe itself isn't properly
folded she just screwed up all the
heroes which serves its purpose and it
works for what it is but from there you
basically end up picking up with her
traveling to that to the god quarry
alongside alongside the guy that
basically you know
with Loki the chronicler more or less
and then you end up having Loki who
travels directly to go see the x-men now
this is where Loki kind of goes back
into being his normal self where he goes
to visit what passes for the x-men here
and actually comes across a dupe pool
now do pool is a combination of dupe and
Deadpool and dupe is amazing - I love
dupe he's like this Omega level
character that just like never got fully
fleshed out and he had all kinds of
crazy powers he was part of X statics
for a little while but doop doop is
awesome due to all do I love doop but
he's like Wolverines the only one who
ever understands him like it's one of
the craziest things Wolverines the only
one who can understand his language
nobody ever understands anything he says
but Dube is awesome like like I love the
character of Duke I feel like we should
do a character do a video on him you
know just like like like cover his story
or something along those lines at the
origin of Duke I don't know if he
actually has a definitive origin or not
I guess we should look that up but still
with Loki showing up to meet Wolverine
we end up finding out that this is
basically Wolverine and Emma Frost
merged into a singular person which is
kind of strange because you would think
it would be in frost in Cyclops but it's
basically Wolverine and emma frost
merged into a singular person which
means that is all the abilities of
wolverine combined with the really Omega
level telepathy this super powerful
telepathy of Emma Frost which is kind of
cool because when it'll fall scans the
mind of Loki emma frost i guess really
wolverine realizes Loki's telling the
truth but ultimately shuts his door the
faces says I don't want to have anything
to do with what's going on here you know
let sleeping dogs lie let our universe
be the way it is so again it seems very
House of M in the sense that Wolverine
has no idea how things are supposed to
be instead he's just kind of like well
you know like this is the universe the
way it's always been the difference is
that in the house of in the universe
Wolverine woke up realizing things
weren't right like he woke up realizing
things aren't the way they're supposed
to be and he was a way to for business
to kind of write it into the story but
here it seems like Wolverine alongside
everybody else it's totally aware of
what's going on like he's totally aware
of the fact that like this reality seems
to be an absolute truth he doesn't know
anything outside of that so it's kind of
cool and it's kind of interesting but
again it's really left to Loki to try to
find some way to basically save his
universe and kind of you know set this
one back to the way that is supposed to
be it's kind of crazy but honestly I
have no idea what direction that's gonna
take okay so we are getting into
infinity wars part 4 and again this is
kind of interesting this is uh
issue number 4 is a little strange it's
more of like plot building but it's kind
of crazy because in truth it feels a
little bit rushed
jury Dugan does here is he actually kind
of takes a couple concepts from the
House of M a lot of people know what
House of M is right it's a story where
Scarlet Witch whoops reality and then
creates a new one and then really she
eliminates a current reality then
creates a new one where like everybody's
most subconscious dreams come true
essentially but in this one Gomorrah
with the Infinity stones had basically
merged all these heroes together so
quote-unquote cut the universe's
population in half by like merging
people together and then threw them all
in soul world and then created like a
whole universe within soul world as it
was kind of interesting because
initially Dugan didn't really seem to
explain that traditionally soul world is
like its own world I guess it has like
rivers and streams and mountains and so
on and so forth and it was always
depicted a certain way then Marvel came
back later and basically turned Sol
world into the Marvel Cinematic Universe
version of Snow world and so what it
kind of happened here is it was like
Gamora had sent all these characters
into Soul world and then built a house
in Soul world and then put them all
inside the house so they don't really
know what soul world looks like they're
not really familiar with it and said
they're all just kind of residing in
this universe she threw in there now by
merging them all together Marvel gave us
infinity warps at the end of the day it
wasn't really meant to be taken
seriously and I may or may not cover it
I don't really know I mean I don't
really care much about the characters
and so in infinity warps but one of the
characters that was or really a couple
characters that were merged here were
Wolverine and Emma Frost and of course
we talked about that in the last video
that was Wolverine and Emma Frost being
sort of merged together is Wolverine
with Emma Frost telepathy and initially
Loki was one of the characters who had
been thrown into this universe when
everything when when Gamora sort of
changed everything and so look he was
like the only person that truly knew
what was going on but in this instance
out with Loki speaking directly with
with Wolverine it's just kind of this
thing where like Wolverine had scanned
his mind he basically read his mind to
see what was going on not only that one
of the things that Jerry Dugan
introduces here is something called
Devon drew and of Ondra is essentially
this object or this this concept is
created for the purpose of like
consuming the occupants of soul world
now again this is Jerry Dugan sort of
making things up or at least creating
new things because remember soul world
was a very peaceful place can't you know
contrary to the way in which a person
would arrive in Seoul war which is a
sake this soul stone would literally
siphon off their soul until the whole
thing was was absorbed and then their
soul resided in Soul world proper and
this Devolder is kind of like this this
being that was either created by Gamora
or has always existed and we'll talk
more about
the world of underplays and you know
with regards to the story here in a
little bit but like Devon Nerdist kind
of shows up where at least one of the
aspects of Devon drew shows up and of
course it's basically fought off by the
combined efforts of Loki and Wolverine
and Emma Frost brought together and so
what is up happening is that sort of in
the middle of all this you end up having
like like Wolverine who you know Diamond
patchy basically says look I'll send a
thought to myself y'all remind myself of
something so ii thought to myself to a
version of myself in the future of this
universe which basically merges with the
phoenix force now this is not new this
is not Jerry Dugan sort of just grabbing
it out of nowhere this is actually going
on in the in the Thor comic books the
Mighty Thor comic books as a backup
feature but nonetheless with this
version appearing out of nowhere is just
kind of like hey look you know I could
basically fix this for you or at least
you know separate Wolverine and Emma
Frost and then just sort of go from
there now this is your redoing kind of
playing it fast and loose with the
Phoenix the Phoenix's power has always
been ambiguous for those of you guys who
are who are new to Marvel the Phoenix's
powers are really one of those things
worse just like whatever right a writer
wants the Phoenix force to do is what
the Phoenix force can do its power is
technically limitless like that's kind
of something that's been established
over the years the other half of this is
the Phoenix force or at least this
future version of Wolverine with the
Phoenix force also has the power stone
and so that's one of the things that's
kind of hit on here and that's where you
sort of get a little bit of Secret Wars
and a little bit of a house of em
brought in here and there since that in
Secret Wars you had an affinity gauntlet
that was assembled because the the
Secret Wars event the battle world
basically dealt with like all these
different universes sort of housed
together and so it was a different
infinity stone from the various
universes that were all brought together
to create a unifying Infinity Gauntlet
in this instance if a new universe is
created then a new a new set of Infinity
stones has to exist in that universe now
I remember it didn't originally work
that way when it came to the Infinity
stones back in really back in in the
Thanos quest stories the phallus had
basically laid out the origin of the
Infinity stones like some being existed
before all things and it was lonely and
then you know basically channeled its
energy or love the fastest of its energy
into the Infinity stones and dispersed
them across the universe and then that
goes into the future stories of Marvel
where every universe has its own
Infinity Gauntlet and the Infinity God
will only work in that one universe this
changes that what the entire basis
behind infinity wars does is it changes
it entirely and says well the reality
stone will actually let you jump from
one universe to the next which
technically is not supposed to happen so
again it's Jerry Dugan sort of shifting
things up but with the Power Stone being
used this allows you
to again amplify their own power and
manipulate the powers of others and
while it is kind of a stretch here
Jerry Dugan uses us to say that a person
with the power stone can split those who
were merged to split him apart and so
this is kind of Ari from House of M
right like the house of an event
basically established like a new
universe was created nobody remembered
how things were supposed to be except
for Wolverine and then Wolverine
basically woke up like well really well
along side Leila Miller woke up Emma
Frost Emma Frost are using her telepathy
to wake up other people and that led to
you know the house of him being changed
back to the main moral universe in the
scholar which took away all the mutants
powers or at least 98% of the mutant
populations powers it really kind of
invokes those things and brings them in
it's just one of those things where
stories kind of build on each other in
that capacity now following this with
the Power Stone being given to Loki Emma
Frost takes it because she's kind of
like I don't trust you man and there's
no reason for her to not only that
Wolverine goes to basically open the
refrigerator and another aspect of d'von
drew shows up and this is one of the
things that Jerry Dugan doesn't really
explain
he doesn't really tell us if Devon dray
is more of like a hive mind concept you
know like we are all Devon draw all
these different you know spiders kind of
soul eating entities that exists out
there or all just Devon drew is kind of
like a hive mind existing in different
aspects or if there really is one Devon
drew out there and these are all just
like fractions of itself we're not
really given an explanation to that but
wool rain kind of faces off against
these things and then basically seems to
get eaten and then you have Emma Frost
who takes the Power Stone as she
alongside Loki basically leave now at
this point we switch over to Gamora now
where everything that goes on that Lisa
we've talked about so far takes place in
Soul world where Gamora is is in
alternate universe in this alternate
reality this is one that we talked about
before where this alternate universe
version of Loki had basically managed to
access or at least pick up Thor's hammer
and then is powered by all the Infinity
stones the difference here seems to be
like Gamora taking the hammer of Thor
which is interesting to see that she's
worthy but it's kind of fudging the
numbers a bit we know just from like
Jonathan Hickman's Avengers of New
Avengers that not every hammer of Thor
and every universe is the same we saw
like a different universe where there
was a version of Thor who was unworthy
and the hammer was made for an unworthy
Thor so we've seen them like shift
around and change around a little bit
but Gamora taking the hammer of Thor
seems to give her the upper hand on this
version of Loki and in turn she goes in
a taxon and of course she kills him in
the process now in this alternate
reality in the previous video
we'd also talked about how he had file
eval and we had we
moondragon and I want to offer a little
more of an explanation on these
characters so in Marvel Comics
originally you had the original Captain
Marvel marvel of the Kree Empire and he
was popular for a time but where his
popularity started waning Marvel killed
him off in 1984 with his own self-titled
death book which was written by jim
Starlin and so following that there
wasn't really a Captain Marvel for a few
years I mean you had like Monica Rambeau
who took up the mantle and then after
her you had genus Val and Judas felt was
okay I mean he wasn't really like that
great of a Captain Marvel it was
marvellous him to basically try to find
a way to like replace the original
Marvel ever the most part they didn't
really seem to enjoy the character until
you got to file a valve and the way this
played out was that in 2004 as part of
joke Asada's grand scheme to rework
Marvel Comics entirely what they did is
they had the the fourth volume of the
Marvel series that starred genus Val he
went nuts and he was manipulated by
cosmic entities and then like recreated
reality and in this new universe that
was created you essentially ended up
having like the version of you know
Alyssia I think is Alyssia or Elysium
who originally created genus fel who
created another version called
Phi Laval and so as a result of this you
kind of had two versions in the same
universe and then when everything was
set back to normal Phi Lavelle came with
him and that was basically Morrow's it's
him to kind of back in a new Captain
Marvel with the intention of killing off
units Val and having phyla vel take up
the mantle for herself that was mobile
comics way of of introducing a new
version of the character going into
annihilation the whole idea of of Dan
Abnett sort of consolidating the entire
Marvel landscape the entire model cosmic
landscape which came with annihilation
so that's why you had like a lot of
those huge cosmic scopes that were going
on with annihilation annihilation
conquest the restoration of the Nova
Corps than its entire decimation and so
on and so forth that's why oh that
story's so singularly important but
father Vale was very very very very very
popular really she still is depending on
you know in at least in certain circles
now of course moon dragon has a far more
in-depth history than Phi Laval moon
dragon is Heather Douglas she's the
daughter of Drax a destroyer and it was
believed that she was killed when Thanos
showed up on earth for the first time to
kind of access the Cosmic Cube and it
killed Arthur Douglas who is resurrected
as Drax for the purpose of killing
Thanos Heather was taken to heightened
by the father of Thanos and then raised
to be someone who could defeat him she's
one of the most powerful telepathic
characters in Marvel Comics but she died
a long time ago she died and there will
not really a long time she died during
the events of annihilation conquest
pretty sure is when she was killed but
the fact remains that that for her and
file of ELQ they were a romantic couple
like they were together they had a
really strong amount of chemistry which
is one of the things you didn't see that
often at marvel at the time and people
really really did enjoy it but again you
know kind of enough expose about these
about these two characters what Jerry
Dugan does is he actually plays it
pretty smart because of the fact that
the reality stone is missing from by
Lavelle you end up having like Gamora
who kind of reads her mind with the
intention of finding its location and
then in turn like moondragon sort of
engages like this telepathic battle and
the result is that Gamora learns the
location of the reality stone and then
moon dragons more or less overpowered
and then in an effort to try to destroy
Gamora file of Elle jumps into the
conflict and ultimately of course Gamora
comes out on top and so that leads to
both moon dragon and file of Elle using
the powered their disposal to basically
kind of crack a whole crack a fissure in
the in the alternate reality and then
enter into soul world now the question
is why does this matter because this is
kind of a backdoor way for Jerry Dugan
to bring these characters back to
basically say okay so like now they're
in Soul world so when quote-unquote
everything gets set back they'll come
with it presumably they'll come with it
but following this it really turns into
Emma Frost and Loki just travelling
around and waking people up so of course
you had Kamala Khan miss Marvel who was
merged with Kang the Conqueror kind of a
time-traveling villain The Incredible
Hulk who's merged with ant-man so it's
like a mini Hulk we're just kind of cool
he's like talking so much trash and he's
like three inches tall but again like
like you know when they're split up it's
one of these things were like infinity
warps was very very short-lived
now Lucky's plan is to to kind of create
not really a new infinity watch but to
bring back individuals who are
particularly suited to wield the
Infinity stones each one of them are
going to wield an infinity stone and
that's one thing to bear in mind the
Infinity stones aren't attuned right
it's not like those individuals who are
really really strong telepaths are best
suited for the mind stone those
individuals who are like magic wielders
are suited for the reality stone it be
cool if mod will kind of lined them up
that way but that was never really the
case it was just kind of like hey man
you get an infinity stone you get to be
part of the Infinity watch and it's like
her ray you know and that's that's
really about it but again you have you
know once they actually leave this sort
of pocket dimension inside sole world
and then travel into soul world proper
Adam warlocks basically being like eaten
by one of these giant spiders and Scott
Lang tricks down jumps inside the spider
rose to a gigantic size and then frees
Adam warlock in the process it's pretty
pretty fast-paced and so in response to
this Emma Frost stands is what we mean
more
people like we need more people to fight
alongside us and so she basically starts
waking up are really contacting all
these people and infinity warps and then
just kind of breeze them all into the in
the end of the larger conflict and we
don't really know what the basis behind
this is we can largely assume she's
forming an army and then she's gonna
split them all and double their numbers
set them back to the way they were
before that kind of a thing uh but again
it's very akin to to house of em in that
regard wicking characters up to who they
truly are separating them so on and so
forth and so from there you go to
Gomorrah and flower again you know the
guy who is from Asgard and basically
like going into the well of creation and
when they get there what we end up
learning here is that from d'amours
perspective this dove andra entity the
stuff Andra being which it doesn't seem
as though she created will basically go
through and consume all these souls
inside of this dimension in Soul world
and when it's hunger satiated it'll
basically spin a new universe and so
it's it's kind of strange here and it
doesn't really seem to make a whole lot
of sense it kind of seems like Jerry
Duggars just kind of tell the story for
the sake of telling the story uh but
when this new universe is created
Gomorrah will in turn enter it and then
take control of it and then created
according to her own whims and wants
which really kind of begs the question
why didn't she just do that with the
existing universe inside of soul world I
have no idea the story has to be told I
have no real clue here again it may be
one of these things where like dude is
kind of going through and then it'll
like the final issue will be a kind of
tell-all in terms of what all is going
on here but it's very confusing is very
cloak-and-dagger it's really kind of all
over the place and this one seems to be
kind of just spinning its wheels ah but
again you know what we end up having is
that with with Devon or going through
and is kind of consuming all these souls
again like normal human beings insides
inside this dimension and soul world
there with a lot of the superheroes
basically making it out alive
we end up having like Gamora is kind of
biding her time and just sort of waiting
for devon drayton finish what she's
doing at which point the entire set of
events is being watched by the watchers
now we don't really know what this means
again there's a lot of unanswered
questions in this story we don't know if
the Watchers being here is for the
purpose of just watching things unfold
we don't know if they're actually going
to act because remember when the
watchers appear in Marvel Comics it's
basically like a huge thing is about to
happen there's gonna be like this huge
paradigm shift but we don't really know
what all it means you really walk to the
watchers been dead since the events of
original sin so there's one here who
actually looks exactly like we're
watching the one with the fire coming
out of his head he looks exactly like
who watching which means this version
may have come back or it's just a whole
different version of his character we
don't really know a lot of unanswered
questions this is this seems like one of
those stories at most
writing for the sake of writing it just
kind of like set everything back to
rights so it's kinda like hey so what if
Infinity Gauntlet ended with like a
reboot more or less like what if we did
we were supposed to do after the events
of secret Wars and actually reboot the
universe we don't know if that's the
case it's kind of strange in terms of
how all this is happening but again you
know it's one of those stories worst is
kind of informational in the middle
ground
not a whole lot really happens and just
kind of set in the stage for things to
come so picking up with infinity Wars
part 5 again in this part we really kind
of pick up in this in soul worlds now
again these guys are all fighting to
vondre and and again this is kind of a
new introduction here by Jerry Dugan and
that's one of the crazy things is a lot
of stuff is being changed here that's
one of things we talked about the
previous videos is a lot of things are
being changed here so world never looks
like this now of course we can basically
attribute this to the fact that Marvel
the Marvel Comics is now copying the
Marvel Cinematic Universe as opposed to
the Marvel Cinematic Universe copy
Marvel Comics but the overall gist here
is that with Devon drah is basically
this entity that exists to kind of go
through and consume everything inside of
soul world which is kind of strange
because for what we've gathered so far
Gamora has basically acquired the soul
stones for herself to kind of recreate
the universe but in order to do this or
to get the heroes out of the way she can
find them all to soul world and then
accidentally merge them all together in
the in the first place which kind of
begs the question why didn't you just
wipe them all out with assault with the
infinity gems you know with with the
Infinity Gauntlet probably because we
already saw the annals do that once and
I guess you can't do the same gag twice
but nonetheless while all that fight is
going on between the merged heroes in
and of Ondra you end up having Emma
Frost miss Marvel Kane the Conqueror
ant-man Scott Lang Loki and the
Incredible Hulk
who were kind of off on a mission of
their own now we don't know the
specifics of this mission is just one of
the things where Emma Frost is just kind
of like hey we have to go to this
particular location now that's one of
things to bear in mind here Jerry Dugan
does just kind of there's a lot of hand
waving in terms of like why things are
happening likewise Emma Frost go into
this location how do all these things
unfold it's kind of well I mean you know
they are and that's just kind of these
kind of have to run with it but the
locations are traveling to is basically
where you have child Gamora hanging out
now again we don't know how child Gamora
got here from that from what ravines
here what were being told here for what
we seemed so far that the older version
of Gamora who was confined to sole world
she was there because in the the
old-school comics when you had
Adam warlock and pip the troll and
Gomorrah who operated as kind of the
early days of the infinity watch when
they were confined within Sol world Nick
amor when she left had left a piece of
herself behind so it sort of made sense
that it worked that way and it just kind
of always been that way why child
Gomorrah is here we're not entirely sure
but the explanation is offered almost
immediately and that's kind of the cool
little bit here what we end up finding
out is that when Gomorrah basically took
all the various heroes and put them
inside Sol world that included a portion
of herself a piece of herself now again
it's one of the things where Gomorrah
didn't really seem to recognize it
didn't really seem to notice it and
again a little bit of hand waving going
on here but one of the things that we
have is child Gomorrah playing with a
set of Infinity stones now this is new
this is really Jerry Dugan just kind of
cooking the books a little bit and
that's one of the things to bear in mind
again we've talked about this in
previous videos but when it comes to the
Infinity stones they only work in their
own universe and a universe only ever
has one set of Infinity stones the
Marvel Cinematic Universe only has one
set of Infinity stones the main Marvel
Universe only has one set of Infinity
stones he ultimate universe all these
different alternate realities there's no
universe that exists in Marvel Comics
where you have more than one set of
Infinity stones but because of the fact
that Gamora had basically created kind
of like a duplicate so to speak of the
main Marvel Universe and then threw it
all into soul world that came with the
Infinity stones as well so she basically
created new stones using existing
Infinity stones that's not supposed to
be able to happen you know it's like
wishing for more wishes when it comes to
a genie sure it's a cool idea to have
but at the end of the day it's not
something that can actually be done from
there Loki ends up basically dispersing
the Infinity stones
among the various members of the team of
what's really kind of like this
ramshackle infinity watch now it's kind
of interesting here because what Loki
says is these stones the Infinity stones
themselves aren't operating the way
they're normally supposed to that
they're kind of different from what
we're used to and so what he basically
says is that what we would normally
expect Emma Frost to get the mind stone
because she's such a high-level telepath
but we would expect the Incredible Hulk
to get the power stone because he's just
draw infinite strength instead Loki
starts switching things up it says
actually Emma Stone or Emma Frost is
gonna get a different stone the
incredible hulks gonna get of it you
know get like the space stone different
things like that that it's all gonna
kind of shift up from the normal status
quo because each stone serves a
particular purpose and so what seems to
be going on here as Loki's hitting at
the idea that they're there is basically
getting the stones because they're
serving a purpose as opposed to you know
something that inherently would
to build on their own powered which
again is kind of a part of the status
quo but it still works not only that
these stones because they basically
manipulate the universe basically allow
them to leave soul world now in truth
that's possible that's entirely possible
for example if you had the Infinity
stone the space stone you could use that
to enter Asgard if you wanted to that's
entirely possible as one of these bear
in mind guys is that what you have if
you if you were to imagine like a plate
for example you know just like it like a
dinner plate and on that plate you have
them that that plate is like the main
Marvel Universe then on that plate you
have like Asgard and you've got Olympus
where the Greek gods dwell and you've
got the realm of Dormammu using the
space stone you can go anywhere in that
universe you can hop skip and jump
anywhere within the realm of that
universe to go for like one dimension to
another we've never really seen anybody
do that before because the story's never
called for it but it's entirely possible
and it's within the possibility of those
Infinity stones to pull that off and
that's the reason why in this particular
story while the Infinity stones are
using do originate in Soul world the O
soul world itself is still part of the
universe so they're basically inside a
dimension inside the main Marvel
Universe they can just leave that
dimension and go back into the main
Marvel Universe and that's exactly what
they do they immediately enter into the
realm of Gamora who's basically hanging
out at the quarry of creation fighting
you know Phi Lavelle and and and moon
dragon of course this leads to the
arrival of Emma Frost and so on and so
forth all of whom start facing off
against against Gamora now under normal
circumstances they would never be able
to stop her they would never be able to
defeat Gamora because of the stones she
wields but because they have Infinity
stones that make them her equal then
what this now means is they can use them
for her you know they can begin
literally go toe-to-toe with her and
ultimately come out on top now this is
also a very important thing to bear in
mind here is that when it comes to the
Infinity stones just because a person
possesses them does not mean they can
use them to their full potential that's
one of the big differences one of the
things that Thanos head-on during the
original gauntlet story up by Jim
starlet Thanos has been around for a
long time for like hundreds if not
thousands of years he's been around for
a very very very long time he's acquired
all kinds of knowledge on a wide array
of different things and so using his
intelligence when he accesses the
Infinity Gauntlet he can use it to its
full potential because he's so durable
he could withstand the extreme power it
possesses he won't go crazy by you know
manipulating reality using the reality
stone that was established here in the
events of Thanos quest when he first
gained the gauntlet in the first
we started going through and tracking
down the stones but then you look at
someone like Parker Robbins you look at
someone like 20 Stark you look at
members of the infinity watch like Hulk
or somebody like that and they can't
really use the stone to its full
potential because in truth they're just
not smart enough they don't really have
the mental faculties to pull it off
someone like Reed Richards could do it
you know we've seen him wield the
Infinity Gauntlet but again you know for
someone like Gamora she is I mean she's
not dumb but she's certainly not on the
same level as like Thanos in terms of
intellect or the capability necessary to
handle the full-on mite of the Infinity
Gauntlet so while she can do some pretty
impressive things she's not using the
stones at like 100% she's using him
probably like 70 or 80 percent or
something like that as a result is that
she's able to hold her own but if this
was Thanos in this situation he would
have destroyed them all he would have
found a way to destroy Emma Frost and
all those different characters and they
wouldn't have wiped out you know quick
fast and in a hurry so again gamora's
overpowered pretty readily and it's kind
of cool to see The Incredible Hulk with
a space stone literally just like
ripping her apart like just flying
basically and throwing her into
everything but the other half of this is
remember Loki's got a mission of his own
to basically capture you know to kind of
recreate malt-o-meal near or at least
gain some version of me linear and gain
his own Infinity stones you know gain
the Infinity stones for himself and
that's what he does while everyone is
facing off against Gamora
what Loki does is he starts travelling
around and basically snatching the
Infinity stones off of people basically
just like palming them and tricking
people into believing that he's just
kind of working on their side he steals
from Miss Marvel he steals from Scott
Lang does the same thing that came to
conquer and Emma Frost literally takes
all their Infinity stones and then
teleports away and so and then just kind
of okay well then one the world's going
on here not only that when Loki gets to
whatever this dimension is that he's at
you know inside what seems to be this
quarry of creation it's lined with
Infinity stones there's a ton of
Infinity stones there so again the plot
thickens we don't really know exactly
what it is is taking place here you know
this is kind of the quarry of creation
of like the multiverse but we don't
really know to what extent all this is
being beginning to unfold not only that
the stones themselves are powerless
inside the quarry of creation so again
this seems to exist outside of the
multiverse which makes sense you know I
don't know how you really create the
multiverse while you're inside of it you
kind of have to be outside of it like to
be on verse or something along those
lines and so it was kind of a tail in
here again things are left pretty
ambiguous we basically end up picking up
with like Drax a destroyer with Arthur
Douglas but this is back when he was in
his human form now if those you guys
were not familiar with this the
character of Drax a destroyer was a guy
named Arthur moon dry
and is his biological daughter named
Heather the way this originally played
out in Marvel Comics was that Thanos had
launched an invasion against earth and
when he did he had come across Drax a
destroyer and destroyer come across
Arthur and like destroyed his car in the
process and when that happened Arthur
was dead heather was believed to have
been dead and of course the wife was
killed and what ended up going on here
is is we basically had Heather who was
taken away by the father of fan OHS and
then her telepathy was essentially
unlocked and she was trying to become
one of the more one of most powerful
telepaths in Marvel Comics and then you
ended up having Arthur Douglas who is
basically resurrected from the dead by
Chronos the god for I guess one of the
cosmic entities and in turn was
transformed into Drax a destroyer and
given the sole purpose of basically
tracking down Thanos and destroying him
this situation does not unfold the same
way they do crash into a tree but when
they do the tree is grouped and that's
when Arthur basically begins to say
things like I know this tree I know this
guy so he's basically having flashbacks
to his life as Drax the destroyer so
again this seems to take place inside of
soul world but it's very very ambiguous
there's a lot of cloak-and-dagger going
on here we don't really know exactly
what's taking place it's very very
far-fetched it's really kind of out
there and even a little bit confusing
but it is somewhat interesting it's one
of these stories where Jerry dude is
just kind of like things are happening
and like you'll have to read the next
issue to find out which is of course the
finale again it's kind of crazy to see
this whole this whole scenario unfolds
kind of Wow to see it all take place but
let me know what you guys think down in
the comments section okay so jumping
back into the events of infinity wars to
kind of get you guys caught up for a
second essentially what's going on here
is we only really have like three worlds
going on right now like like from the
perspective of this story we're only
dealing with three universes there's
still an infinite number of universes
out there but from this perspective
we're only dealing with three universes
right now the main Marvel Universe has
really just kind of been annihilated in
its entirety then you have soul world
and then you have of course the quarry
of creation and again like like we've
talked about this in the previous
previous videos that with with soul
world it was never so it was never a
whole universe right like soul world was
just like a little pocket dimension like
imagine that you lived in a universe
that was the size of like New York City
and that's basically what soul world was
it was a tiny little localized space
inside of of the soul stone and it was
kept small because so few people ever
wielded it that the the space that was
needed to house them was always very
very small but I thought you means Loki
had basically taken the the Infinity
stones as they existed in the the real
I'm sorry in the main mobile universe
and basically stole them everybody in
Soul world but then you've also got a
second set of Infinity stones that
reside within soul world and so what it
basically gone on here is that with Loki
taking these stones and then leaving for
the purpose of trying to achieve
whatever this greater goal happened to
be with us never really being told what
it was as soon as he gets out into the
main Marvel Universe what we end up
finding out is there's nothing there
anymore that all you really have heard
is just kind of like this huge vast
empty space and then you have the
Celestials themselves and the Celestials
never talk and that's one of the things
to bear in mind when it comes to
Celestials in Marvel Comics and that's
why when Loki addresses they may never
speak to him and instead one of them
just kind of points over to a particular
direction
Loki goes and looks he looked into a
mirror we don't see what Loki sees as
that's never offered as an explanation
to us he's basically you know it kind of
pulls back the tapestry and he sees what
awaits for him and then he basically
just kind of quits he basically gives up
and says yep that's pretty much it and
it's kind of lackluster in reality it
makes sense if that's something that's
revealed later on down the line but it's
not Loki just pulls back the tapestry
and just says ah yep so this is
basically kind of like a zero sum and
then leaves and it really seems more
like Jiri Duggan's way of just kind of
saying okay we have to wrap this up
somehow and we can't really explore what
goes on with Loki so we'll just kind of
write it off we'll be done and then Loki
will leave and that will be it so he
essentially comes back with the soul
stones from soul world you know because
of course they work within that
localized space and and work within the
quarry of creation and when he brings
them back they're basically given to
what's left of Adam warlock infinity
watch team and then Loki does kind of
jumps on his boat and then just sails
off back to omnipotent city and that's
the end of that it's kind of weird it
really kind of seems to come out of left
field but the fact remains that that
going back to soul world again you have
Devon drew that's kind of interesting
thing there's one of the interesting
things at jury duty in did he's very
much taking a page at a jim Starlin and
what i mean here is that for years and
years for decades Galactus just had this
hunger and more often than not the
hunger of Galactus was attributed to the
fact that he was born out of a dead
universe into a new one and the role he
plays is two main basic aaliyan sure but
like the celestial population doesn't
doesn't go unchecked when they plant
there their seeds inside of a planet so
that that planet will give birth to a
new celestial Galactus goes around and
consumes planets so the Celestials don't
just plant their seed everywhere and
then you've got a universe overrun with
Celestials when jim Starlin came along
and wrote the Thanos miniseries what he
established was that the hunger of
Galactus was actually like an other
dimensional entity now it was a terrible
story it was a terrible idea but
jury did is kind of taken a page out of
that by saying that the reason why the
soul stone hungers for souls is because
it houses the being Devon drew and that
have never really been explained up to
this point it was just the being Devon
drew is there and we were never really
given an explanation of what of what
world of Andra plays outside of the fact
that it just consumes everything inside
and what seems to have gone on here is
that where the soul stone came into
existence when the entity nemesis
scatters essence across the universe in
the form of the Infinity stones that
when the soul stone came into existence
Devon derp was born inside the soul
stone and when that happened to von
Drake had a constant hunger to consume
souls the difference here is that when
infinity Wars happen and Gomorrah
basically took all the life in the main
Marvel Universe put it all inside of of
the soul world and then bent it onto
itself to basically start merging people
in order to essentially conserve space
that what this did is a basically open
to von der up to the idea that there's
just like all these different beings
that are out there now that it can eat
so we're just kind of went on like a
like a feeding frenzy consuming like
everything it could come across until it
happen to come across the heroes here
and so the result is either basically
fighting off against it as best they can
and that's really kind of just what's
going on at the moment they're just
fighting off against it as best they can
and so again things get wrapped up
pretty quickly because you know in order
to kind of deal with this threat what
the Incredible Hulk does is use the the
space stone run up onto von der it
create a black hole inside the entity
which literally just like sucks it into
this singularity and that's the end of
the Fondren it gets wrapped up like that
and again that's this kind of a common
theme in this story is that they just
kind of get wrapped up in like one page
and it's just kind of like okay and so
then you turn around you have Adam
warlock who sits down and says the main
Marvel Universe has basically been wiped
out all you have is the universe inside
soul world and then like they've left
the quarry of creation so all this left
right now is the main Marvel Universe
fold it onto itself in Soul world and so
Adam warlocks idea is to basically
restore everything back to normal the
quandary that that Adam warlock has and
what Jerry Dugan kind of toys with here
is what the aftermath will be will it
certainly be a reboot which is what
Marvel should have done out of Secret
Wars or is everything gonna go back to
normal and the reality is that
everything's gonna go back to normal
everything is gonna kind of reset the
way it was the thing that you take away
from this is that the Infinity warps
universe is basically copied right so I
mean imagine it's a piece of paper a
piece of papers just been folded onto
itself like that's what Gamora dish you
take a piece of paper which was a name
of a universe fold it onto itself and
then put it inside sole world and that's
finiti warps that's the universe that
exists in soul world what Adam warlock
is gonna do is he's gonna copy that
folded piece of paper and then he's
gonna take it out of soul world did he's
gonna unfold it and that's gonna be the
main Marvel Universe going back to
normal and it kind of makes sense in
terms of just fixing everything the
issue that they have here is that
there's basically like they can't leave
infinity warps inside the soul world
forever like they can't leave it there
for all time and so what they end up
doing is creating basically like two
universes and then in turn just sort of
dispersing everything among those two
universes and so it restores infinity
warps and it restores the main Marvel
Universe now what this does going
forward is it lays the groundwork for
Marvel to start exploring infinity warps
which in reality I mean they kind of
tease it a little bit with regards to
the actual infinity war story I didn't
read any of them because none of them
interested me but you know it does leave
the door open for them to start
exploring that or to do whatever they
want with that universe turn it into the
ultimate universe or anything along
those lines they can essentially do
whatever they want here and so once
everything goes back to normal then Adam
warlock kind of has this second the
second struggle which is can we go back
and undo all this like is it possible to
change all this and that's one of things
he kind of deals with you one of these
to bear in mind and this is one of the
things that jim Starlin discuss and
infinity i can't which what it was but
it was the one where Thanos enters the
mind of Adam warlock and Adam warlock
enters of mind of Thanos to see how the
other views all of creation how they
view themselves and how they be the
universe and so on and one of the things
jim Starlin established in that story is
that Adam warlock is a being of order
and structure if the universe were left
to Adam warlock if he had total power
and he could create the universe in his
own image it would be rigid and
structured there would be no real free
thought there would be no real freedom
of choice or anything like that
there'd be no free will and so Adam
warlock is kind of struggling with that
internally in terms of yes I think I can
make everything the way that I want it
to be or I can go back in time and stop
this but there's always consequences
remember branch universe theory so if
Adam warlock goes back and he changes
things then what that means is there's a
universe out there where he didn't
change anything and the question has to
be asked here is which one will become
the main Marvel Universe and so it's
just kind of a risk it's a gamble for
for Adam warlock but at the end of the
day what he does is he makes the choice
he disperses Gamora sins are out there
here's the Infinity stones and says like
I'm basically removing her and sitting
her to a place where she can
quote-unquote do the most good
whatever in the heck that happens to me
and then in turn what he does is he
gives the infinity of Jim's souls rila
he goes right back to the point right
after they get there and he gives
infinity of Jim's Souls and he basically
says each of these Infinity stones can
now make their own decisions they can go
live their lives freely and kind of
disperse now Jerry dude is not pulling
that out of thin air right that's one of
the things that was established and
Brian Michael Bendis is iluminati run on
some degree they have some measure of
sentience because they all want to be
reunited it's one of the rate of the
ways that business explain how it is
people always end up acquiring all the
Infinity stones that if you acquire one
of them it will lead you to all the
others and the more you gather the
easier it will be to locate the others
Adam warlock kind of builds on that and
says now they're sentient beings now
they can go out there forge their own
paths and do their own thing then what
it does is again that sets the stage
from all over to start focusing on
people arbitrarily getting the Infinity
stones introducing new characters some
character we've ever seen or heard of
before who suddenly gains an infinity
stone you know the other half of this is
again gyum or has basically been whisked
off to another location we're not sure
exactly where it is on some far-flung
distant planet where she ends up
uncovering this this really kind of a
tomb slash casket made of rock which
houses the magnets the evil future
alternate personality of Adam warlock
and this is what I want to kind of talk
about for a second when it comes to
count when it comes to stories that we
cover by and large I usually try not to
throw my opinion in there in the extreme
right like I throw it out to you guys
explain what's going on give you guys
some history on the characters who were
there how it all kind of ties together
into the history of Marvel Comics and
then you guys come to your own
conclusions but in reality I don't know
what the point of this story was except
I guess maybe make money it just kind of
didn't really seem to serve a purpose
because in a nutshell here's what
happens
Gamora gets the Infinity stones because
she believes she could fix everything
she does this by taking the main Marvel
Universe folding it in half throwing it
into soul world this introduces infinity
warps basically characters from Marvel
Comics superheroes from omec how many
super villains who have emerged into a
singular being which was kind of fun I
guess if that was your thing what's left
of the heroes basically band together
and they start fighting off against you
know what's essentially the hunger of
the soulstone given physical form in the
form of Devon drew Gamora wants to go to
the quarry of creation to recreate
everything only to find out she can't
the heroes are still fighting to von der
for a little while
they finally make their way out Loki's
there somehow doing something but we
never find out what it is because he
never does it and then he leaves and
goes home and then this story ends and
that's basically it in a nutshell it
doesn't really seem to have served a
purpose at all and more often than not
here's here's one of the important
things I mean if this is a story that's
a stepping stone to something much
bigger didn't did it wasn't really felt
because in Marvel Comics and and really
a couple books as a whole DC Comics
Marvel Comics the whole nine yards when
stories are stepping stones to something
bigger then is
obvious when you feel it right like you
got I can you look at Chris Claremont's
x-men it was nothing but building blocks
that's all it was one builds to two
builds to three builds to fork we got
more modern stories and and you you look
at these events like Loki becoming
sorcerer supreme which happened three
months ago in in Doctor Strange and the
stories serve the purpose of building on
top of things I'm setting the stage for
something else and is tangible and you
can feel it when you're reading the
story for this like everything like this
crazy event happened and now nobody
remembers and it's all basically undone
and it's kind of like okay so like we're
right back where we started
and so it's kinda like what was the
point of it all so I don't know maybe
it's maybe one of you guys got something
out of it more than I did I'm not really
sure me I don't mean to be negative and
overly criticized it's just as a person
who's been reading comics for over 20
years
I see stories like this and they never
usually bode well they never usually
have longevity because they don't lead
to anything it doesn't actually go into
anything instead as a story 5 or 6 arcs
down the line you get basically just say
well we can you can just ignore that and
Burton didn't exist like weird like it's
like spider-verse right like technically
speaking you can pretend like
spider-verse never happened because it
happened between two issues of superior
spider-man like issue 21 and 22 like
it's not like there's an aftermath to
spider-verse where I saw like
spider-verse happens and then it has a
ripple effect throughout the rest of
superior spider-man going into all-new
all-different or I guess the return of
Peter Parker and then all-new
all-different amazing spider-man Spidey
verse is never referenced again I don't
know I mean you know even now is with
secret empire it's still referenced you
know I mean it was just it was
referenced in the superior octopus
one-shot for you know for the spider
getting tie-in so again I don't know I
mean let me know what you guys think
down in the comment section I'm curious
what your take is because again I don't
normally do this but I don't normally
read stories that in this way like
stories don't stories don't usually
happen like this in Marvel comic so it's
kind of crazy and again it doesn't
really seem they're sort of purpose at
all so with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here to come this explain make
sure you guys are the sub button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]